que mériadec raffray secrétaire général
de l' jd et l'association des
journalistes de défense
bonsoir mériadec raffray merci m merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors
pourquoi avoir écrit cette lettre
ouverte et quelles sont précisément les
griefs vous parler de deux mensonges
notamment dans les cas de contamination
au sein des armées
écoutez il y avait effectivement une
pression qui monte au sein des adhérents
journaliste professionnel et spécialiste
des questions de défense de
l'association des juristes de défense et
à moment donné nous sommes notre
vocation est aussi de d'être de dire les
choses
porter la parole de nos de nos
journalistes camara des confrères et
effectivement ces dernières semaines il
ya eu des erreurs des maladresses des
suspicions voire même certains le disent
emploie le mot mensonge à propos comment
10h de l'information ou de nos
informations délivrées par les
communicants de l'institution militaire
et la coupe était visiblement plein il
fallait que nous marquions le coup que
nous prenions date
il est vrai également que le climat vous
la verrez à rappeler est suspicieux là
la communication gouvernementale depuis
le début de cette crise laisse pour le
moins à désirer voire même véritablement
chaotique et il se trouve qu'il y avait
des dysfonctionnements structurels entre
les journalistes de défense et
l'institution et la communication de
défense et que la crise a sans doute
accéléré les difficultés et a causé un
certain nombre de deux sujets plus
graves
il ya des problèmes autour des chiffres
du cor vide dans les armées il ya des
problèmes c'est à dire mériadec raffray
les chiffres sont inexacts ont-ils été
publié difficile pour l'instant on a du
mal à démêler l'écheveau certain jour
es10 effectivement que les chiffres
communiqués ont été faut d'autres disent
que le problème est la complexité des
sources vous savez dans les institutions
je re de l'institution à défense vous
avez des communicants politiques vous
avez les communicants de l'institution
au niveau central qui ensuite vous avez
des communicants qui représentent les
différentes armées touche là
est un peu complexe et peut-être il y a
eu des voix lardé les problèmes des
problèmes de complexité mais certains
dénoncent effectivement des mensonges
c'est à dire des chiffres faux délibérée
ou non c'est le reste a approuvé il ya
eu également la sphère du porte-avions
la contamination dé de l'équipage du
charles de gaulle qui a qui a défrayé la
chronique dans nos rangs et qui continue
de la défrayer certains disent que
l'institution n'a eu qu'à communiquer
des informations inexactes pouvoir
pouvoir même mensongères et qui s'est
encore compliquée on a encore du mal à y
voir on va sans doute un pouvoir en
discuter avec les interlocuteurs et les
responsables de la défense
mais certains journalistes disent
effectivement qu'on leur a menti sur sur
les informations liées à cette
contamination
voilà donc et puis le troisième sujet
qui lui a fait déborder le vase c'est
l'histoire des sportifs militaires
français qui aurait été je prends je
prends le conditionnel contaminées en
octobre dernier lors des jeux mondiaux
de hua hin en chine qui a été révélé ces
derniers jours et les attaches analystes
pensent que les l'institution militaire
n'a pas forcément tout dit ou dit des
choses qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité l'institution militaire nitoo
contout que gide positif pour danser
danser dans ce groupe de journalistes de
parents de tif tiff militaire je vais y
arriver alors vous parlez également de
problèmes structurels qui n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui un et pas forcément de
cette crise sanitaire qui ont été
exacerbées quel type de problèmes
structurels vous êtes un spécialiste
défense et vous dites il faut pas
forcément la primauté de l'information
mais en tout cas les xacti t
l'exactitude de ses informations en tant
que spécialiste il est clair que le seul
la défense est un sujet compliqué
complexe et et qu'on y touche très vite
à des questions sensibles car me parle
de vie et de mort on y parle
de secret défense on y parle de
souveraineté d'indépendance française
est donc scellé journaliste et
spécialiste des questions de défense
sont habitués à travailler avec des
informations fiables recoupé des
chiffres précis pour justement se forger
une crédibilité auprès de leurs
interlocuteurs
et quand on a en ce moment des dés son
cloche divergents des gens qui donnent
des chiffres approximatifs voire même
pas de chiffres tout cela crée quelque
chose de malsain
par ailleurs et ça c'est une dérive
institutionnelle parfois pas forcément
lié au ministère de la défense mais on
voit des communicants qui communiquent
en fonction de dax stratégiques qui sont
internes qui sont se poser selon des
objectifs qui sont un terreau de
l'institution et le journaliste ne n'est
plus que finalement quelqu'un qui vient
occasionnellement s'insérer dans cette
cette stratégie alors que en normalement
le communicant et là évidemment pour
parler aux journalistes et pour écouter
ces questions et non pas et non pas pour
les prendre si uniquement l intéresse sa
stratégie voyez alors ça c'est quelque
chose de fond et puis vous avez un
troisième sujet c'est un sujet politique
il ya des journalistes qui se plaignent
des pressions exercées par au niveau
politique de la communication
institutionnelle est bon ça c'est une
c'est également une dérive qui est
relativement répandue aujourd'hui c'est
depuis ces quelques de quelques années
quelques ailes quels types d'impression
précisément des coups de fil des coups
de fil pour des articles qui entre
guillemets aurait déplu ou ou des coups
de fil pour dire qu'il faut pas
forcément travailler sur ce type de
sujet plutôt d'autres voilà des choses
comme ça des choses un peu étonnante
mais encore une fois qu'ils sont là pour
le coup plutôt au niveau politique et
pas avait pas au niveau des communicants
politiques de la majorité actuelle ou de
pouvoir politique c'est à dire on l'a on
désigne davantage la cible la cible
cabinet défense évidemment oui alors ça
c'est un problème qui est qui est
particulier à la défense où vous pensez
ou est ce que c'est un problème en
pleurer quand non non je pense pas que
ce soit un problème particulier
d'essence je vais vous dire il faut
aussi sourire quand on a des pressions
c'est que a priori le travail est plutôt
bon vous voyez c'est on peut le voir
de le voir aussi comme ça donc c'est
plutôt bon ça veut dire que les articles
voilà disent des choses on est que les
articles ne disent pas seulement la
communication institutionnelle mais moi
je constate on le voit avec la faire
démasquer on le voit aussi avec le fan
la femme le fameux épisode de la
rubrique désintox sur gouvernement.fr
que le gouvernement a tenté de mettre en
place et qu'il a été obligé de retirer
sous la pression de la grande majorité
des sociétés de rédaction du journal
n'avait bien sûr suivi cette affaire
on voit bien que à un moment donné la
meilleure façon de lutter contre l'effet
que news les choses nouvelles en tout
cas dans notre spécialité c'est
d'alimenter les journalistes en
informations en temps et en heure
c'est-à-dire pour alimenter cette
machine médiatique qui fonctionne et
autant que faire se peut d'ailleurs un
peu en amour car ça permet aux
journalistes de mettre en perspective
ces informations est de produire une
information de qualité et c'est
évidemment comme ça qu'on arrivera à
trouver une alternative au fait que nous
n ont pas en désignant tel ou untel ou
en faisant des pressions sur les
journalistes comme comme certains le
trouvent que on en fait beaucoup
beaucoup en ces dernières semaines des
armes et vous inviter à qu'est ce que
vous en attendez précisément c'est la
dernière qui avait coûté vous savez
quand il ya un problème il faut parler
en fait on en face de nous des
communicants le propre du métier de
communicant c'est d'établir des contacts
des relations et de pouvoir prendre son
téléphone et de parler et l'a
visiblement il y avait un problème
puisque le comment dirais-je le il y
avait une espèce de la compréhension
entre les communicants et juristes qui
est pour le coup paradoxale pour ce
métier alors donc on va parler on va on
va parler on va essayer de dépassionner
le débat et surtout de 2d personnaliser
les choses parce qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'énervement beaucoup de l'hystérie
aussi peut-être en cette fin de
déconfinement la période est compliquée
pour tout le monde je vous rappelle que
beaucoup de journalistes travaillent
vous le savez bien dans des conditions
de plus en plus difficile ethnique
voilà donc tout ça va être pris en
compte mis sur la table et je crois que
les militaires sont des gens rationnels
avec lesquelles e
évidemment on peut parler voilà il faut
aussi que les responsables mais qui ne
sont pas décisionnaire les militaires à
toujours vous avez raison pas toujours
merci beaucoup mériadec raffray d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france
bercy votre invitation mais galli